burger show yeah burger show
you do it man
burger show
[Music]
rhett and link have eaten tons of fast
food burgers on their show good mythical
morning
all in the name of research so when it
comes to giving opinions on food
these guys pull no punches what better
time for a burger battle right me versus
her own team member mythical chef josh
two fast food experts at the height of
our powers the challenge
build the ultimate fast food burger mash
up by cherry picking elements from our
favorite burger chains all i can say is
may the best burger win game on so we've
eaten a lot of burgers in real life and
an internet life you have two
connoisseurs of burgers
fast food burgers even especially and i
feel like i've fed you so many fast food
burgers that i feel like i'm a real life
data crunching machine well i feel like
you have an unfair advantage because you
know what our palettes want and need you
have home court advantage at this and
i'm fine with that i will take it i'll
take a win with an asterisk i don't care
i think the key to a good fast food
burger is that it behaves as a unit
there is a big mac taste there is a
quarter pounder with cheese taste there
is a baking soda baconator just melts
together and a special sauce is i think
an important you're talking like
thousand island special sauce i'm just
saying no no no no a special sauce okay
the x factor it could be anything as
long as it's special and as long as it's
sauce so we only signed one of you guys
checks yeah true uh that person better
be better i you know we'll see am i
fired if i don't win yes oh you didn't
that wasn't discussed we're ready let's
do it baby let's go
[Music]
all right alvin
we're making the western
we're making the western bacon buttery
shack one of my favorite things jack in
the box they just straight take a pad of
butter and throw it on the burger and
then we got the the bacon and the onion
rings we're doing tempura onion rings
okay that's an ode to the western bacon
one of the og best burgers of all time
from carl's jr i agree they used to sell
them two for three dollars and i used to
take two of them and i would go eat them
in the 24 hour fitness sauna back in my
hometown and that's an og move jesus i
should probably stop talking about this
we can probably just make it yeah let's
make this let's do it man all right so
you want to drop those tempura yeah i'm
here for a reason all right you're gonna
be my sous chef today yeah i got it pop
that in i'm gonna get this burger
seasoned up one of my favorite textures
in the whole freaking world is something
crispy that has soaked up something
saucy i agree you know what i mean
agreed we're going a little bit fancier
on this blend here so we're going like
right you're not getting individual
muscle cuts and a fast food burger you
have no idea of course not that but i
still want to make this tasty still a
cook-off at the end of the day yeah yeah
uh so short rib and chuck so you don't
drop that bacon and fryer we're just
gonna fry up the bacon bacon's gotta be
on there preferred method of cooking
bacon is in the deep fryer yeah white
american there's something almost a
little bit elevated about it even though
the fact you know all it's missing is
food dye right you know what i mean yeah
but still i dig on it's not doesn't have
a spray tan
so we got a barbecue spice compound
butter right here and i'm gonna pop it
on the cheese on the cheese and then
we're gonna try and get that like slowly
up to temp as this burger finishes
cooking i just wanted to do this for
shock and effect it's going to do
nothing but we did it
it's listened it's shiny so the butter's
going on there that's the homage to jack
in the box right okay and then we got
the barbecue sauce right here that i'm
gonna spread on both sides of the bun
this is the homage to carl junior
western bacon but this is a carolina
gold barbecue yeah that's not brown yeah
man so this carolina gold so this is the
mustard base and the chilies are an
homage to both in and out these are
literally the chopped chilies from in
and out on the secret menu don't know if
anyone knows that you can get those but
then it's also a little bit of a
reference to shake shack smoke shack
okay all right man we're going
pop those grab a couple of these bad
boys i'm getting really hungry this
looks delicious one more drizzle
this is how you know you're a [ __ ]
online internet chef pro right there
just sexy ass food we gotta have to wrap
especially a burger this freaking big
i'm trying to remember how to do this
wait hold on hold on i could do it for
you can you do it for me i'm a pro dude
hold on can i smear it with butter first
yeah let's do it all right i want to
smear a little bit of the
dry rub butter cause that's one of the
best parts about a fast food oh yeah it
has to be greasy
it like this
put your palm on there
give it a tug
oh bam oh that is a sexy baby diaper
voila
that's gord i'm i'm stoked on this man i
can't wait to try that western bacon
buttery shack let's do it look at this
burger i'm proud of that it's just
slipping and sliding
yeah i like that sound
super good thanks man i mean [ __ ] this
is not a fast food burger you think it's
gonna be a dog fight you getting scared
a little bit do you think i went too far
away from fast no this is this is
gourmet you gonna show me what's up
though
mine will not nearly be as complicated
but
i'm still confident i gotta dazzle him
with [ __ ] somehow that's good
that's a good ass burger baby
what do you got man hit me up your
burgers is gonna be tough to beat i see
we're working with somewhat similar
flavor profiles yeah these are were
specifically made for me it's a classic
sourdough bowl so this this is the the
jack-in-the-box sourdough jack sourdough
jacks you criticized mine for being too
artisanal here you are with this like i
had a special baker bake my sourdough
bowls and ring molds look it just
wouldn't be the [ __ ] burger show if
we didn't have custom bread made another
thing about fast food msg yes it's
everywhere everywhere right i feel so
dumb for not using it in mine so i have
that forms of msg
all over this burger right so we have oh
snap doshi rehydrated onion
you you have who are you to criticize
mine for not being a fast food you're
using doshi in the end but dehydrated
onions are a secret in fast food burgers
sure that's how mcdonald's yeah
mcdonald's does it it saves space
no prep you just pour water on it but we
poured dashi miso ranch bacon and then i
got vegemite butter are you kidding me
yeah dude this is a flavor bomb this is
a 90 10 blend
what they have to put the calorie
content on their menu
so they definitely save so that they can
put all the other fats everywhere else
interesting so 9010 patty
give it a little bit of a smash with
your fingers it wouldn't be a sourdough
jack if there wasn't any bacon
but look at this my yard damn that's
sexy
we hit it with
the vegemite butter
this is an homage to culver's then i'm
using havarti it's like fancy but not
yeah really yeah and it's also a really
great melting cheese and i'm gonna hit
this with the torch so i can get a
little whoa
there it goes
miso ranch this goes on the bottom not
on the top we're gonna hit it with the
dashi onions pickled serranos this is an
homage to in and out then we'll top it
with a patty dude
dude that is a tightly edited burger i'm
so stoked to eat this
[Music]
but check this out
we also have a container of wraps
gotta ranch each bite individually
exactly can i jump in yeah try oh my god
hold on so i'm wrenching each bite round
two each bite i'm ranching each plate
we're gonna get a fat gobbler ranch on
there i'm gonna do like the the hoover
bite where you just suck out the juice
yep
oh
this guy knows how to eat
what do you think
still beefy
gotta be there's no running from flavor
in this burger
all right
msg
oh nice
that's the move unreal that's the move
this is for real there's gonna be
it's gonna be a dog fight yeah it's
gonna be tight dude drop down that's
gonna be a very tight one
i'm gonna be the best man win
god i'm taking him something i'm putting
this in my pocket for later
all right chefs what i've prepared for
you today this is the western bacon
buttery shack all the best things about
the western bacon cheeseburger from
carl's jr the jack-in-the-box buttery
jack and the smoke shack from shake
shack so we have a short rib ground
chuck burger there's a carolina gold
barbecue sauce
and then we got tempura onion rings
deep-fried bacon chopped chili relish
and then a little bit of barbecue rub
compound butter
yeah cause that's exactly how it would
look if you got it from a fast food hey
that's how it looks in the commercials
yeah it looks the commercial it does
i've never seen this come out of a
drive-through
just crush it down shake it up throw it
against a wall and then eat it i mean i
feel like you know just recently when we
had a conversation about my favorite
barbecue style
i told you that mustard sauce was my
favorite barbecue sauce
i just feel like this is not fair and
it's my favorite too
so i can't unlearn the information that
i know i'm being set up here
i should have known dank it
boom and sink it
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
all right
that sounds like muffy giggles
that mustard comes hard and it comes
quick
that's a really really tasty burger
you've got the crunch of the bacon i
like a nice crispy bacon with that
there's a lot of sweetness in this thing
i would almost go as far as to say that
i almost like the sauce too much
[Music]
you know what i'm getting at here that
sauce is so good and also so strong
because of the mustard okay but i feel
like it might be it's like when you
invite
like somebody like your friend to the
party who like wears like really
loud pants and you're like hey man
you're gonna come to the don't do their
thing
yeah zach can you sit down behind can
you just wear jeans zach we got we've
had enough of your pants if it was like
a loud pants party then you might want
zach there right is this a loud pants
party well i mean how loud are your
pants right now
they're just black jeans i gotta be
honest i'm more of a thin burger man and
then if you want to double or triple
stack it
maybe throw some cheese in the middle i
don't know what you got in store for me
oh man not that okay
[Laughter]
change the burger
[Music]
all right guys yes there we go
this is inspired by the sourdough jack
sans tomatoes thank you i use a 90-10
lean beef
because lean beef is what they use at
most fast food places okay serrano
chili's
dashi hydrated onions so i got
dehydrated onions and i put dashi in it
the whole goal is to
create like a flavor bomb without having
it look like 90 layers of different
things no disrespect
the burger's glazed in
the first thing that i smell
is the burger okay good so it's
definitely a burger yeah take the first
bite
the first thing i smell is not mustard
you've passed that test it's definitely
a burger well and it's very reminiscent
of i know you're talking about the in
the box
but i feel like that was a follow-up to
the frisco burger back damn frisco's uh
which would have been [ __ ] you're
bringing me back now well we're better
that's where
we're going parties for us on the east
coast you know that was a hardy's thing
but like the frisco burger was my
childhood go-to if i was gonna treat
myself mama get me a frisco burger you
just unlocked the westworld memory of
this robot here yeah i just hit him with
that uh ratatouille
but then i lost an ant to a trolley car
yeah right
it's yet right we got these really cool
side cups that look like fast food
dipping yeah containers you got a prop
with miso ranch in it
josh didn't have any props i can get you
a prop you want prop no i don't know
you didn't think you needed a property i
was trying to give you a compliment okay
i'm going to just do a a little dab
just a little dab to do you got a lot of
energy drinks in the system i love how
if you really achieve it there's so much
more burger than bun oh oh look at that
look at that cheese stretch
what are we thinking
wow the burger's amazing so if you don't
mind i'm gonna give it a look-see oh
there's definitely bacon in there i
forgot to say that there's definitely
some bacon yeah so there's crushed up
bacon
pounded into the patty i tried not to
chef it up don't you don't you look like
you just are accepting defeat josh i ate
that burger too i agree with you man
it's a hell of a burger i mean it is i i
will say you just said you shipped it up
yeah i do feel like see we're getting a
little bit out of
fast food like i don't feel like i'm
going to drive through i feel like i'm
i'm planted in a booth and somebody's
waiting on me neither one of these feels
like something you're gonna get at a
fast food they both shift it up
it feels but i can i can sense
the inspiration i can sense the spirit
of the fast food burger behind it the
only thing that is sending me to josh's
is it's it's a little bit more in fast
food territory i think both of them were
incredible burger accomplishments i
think both of them sent me to a place
like accessed a memory this is like
choosing one of my children
to sacrifice i'll be a kid and uh so i
mean i feel like this is why there's two
of us because i feel like i got to just
abstain i think there is a tie in my
book oh well good i'm voting for josh's
yes let's go
but only you always my favorite i mean
if we if he loses then we have to fire
him and then it does get complicated
they're gonna hate the paperwork yeah
alan you're too busy to work with us
it's okay i know how it is you know
we're doing this
we got to keep you know
we got to do right by our own i know i
got it thank you guys thanks thanks for
trying
indulging with us so fabulous anytime
you need this service this particular
service it will be here the drop of a
hat
does josh actually get like a medal or
something i mean like you know usually
we have like a golden spatula
something like that
you get this
i'll take that i'll take that i'll take
that i don't normally love the untouched
burger show
that's my way to end everything i just
got like magical kitchen burger show the
winner the burger show
burger show yeah burger show
burger show
[Music]
what's up y'all it's your boy alvin
kylon of the burger show make sure you
like
subscribe and hit that notification bell
if not for me
for the burger